(Christmas music playing)
Happy vlogmas
So right now it is 7:54 am
December 1st
Welcome to Vlogmas
This is not a promise
that I'm going to vlogging every day
But this is the promise that I would try my almost best to post a video almost every day in December
Vlogging every day but trying to make high-quality videos
It's not an easy task.
So I am not planning on killing myself to try to YouTube guys videos every day while trying to live my life
But what I will be doing is I already filmed a bunch of really fun Christmas videos similarly fun collabs
And today will really respond my Vlogmas videos
Because of this
It's the STAR WARS advent calendar!!
My friend Ro gave me this present. I'm sweared to you, probably like, it feels like two months ago. She's like it gotta open this on December 1st.
Say basically had my calendar December 1st open Ro's present
BB-8 is freaking sliding down a snow bank
And this snow is being pumped by a storm tuber on like the snow blow like she's everything about this box. It's just perfect.
Oh, boy!!
I'm also got my STAR WARS pajama pants that my mom got me like last year for Christmas
Man, STAR WARS, I'm so height to the new movie, like, I absolutely cannot wait
And I'm also just gonna apologize 'cause I'm kind just still so sleeping
I have a little slap much this month at all, well, last month
'Cause it's December!! It's not like Vlogmas
But... it's, whatever, I'm doing... I don't know. Welcome my channel.
Let's open this up
Oh my gosh it's so pumped, is so pumped
Oh, shoot! I did a wrong! I just opened up a whole, an entire thing and not to suppose to do that
I gotta close this backup.
If you guys have this, and is this spoiler?
Stop watching now, and skip to... a few minutes later.
And technically the time is spoiler because a whole of... what is on here is inside of you here
There's a little face
I am so hyped for Christmas!!
♪ have a holly jolly Christmas ♪
♪ It's the best time of the ♪
So I got some mini figures
Here's all setup. We gotta put him... I don't know. Putting by the presents.
Well, this setup over here, in my kitchen office
Wait a minute.
I am so confused right now because after father inspection of this set,
clearly these numbers are out of ordering even think that I would be something that I would be noticed when I first opened it up, but I did not.
So clearly,
Oh my gosh, I mean I don't it makes this sense.
Why of the all the out of order? I don't understand.
But leave the way. That means now I get to open two today because I actually open up 10 and the 1 is still... now open.
Wow!
Oh no
How do I put together?
Okay, alright.
Well. now everything that I thought that was new is lie.
So guess now I've two days now open my calendar
So really this is just a quick little vlog, just say hello and welcome to December
It's kind of crazy because this is entire year just flow by so quickly.
Editing an entire video, this is gonna take me probably like 4 hours to make this video is gonna's like I wanna 2.
So that's what I decided to make a quick vlog, just to say hi and a lot of you guys have been missing my vlogs and I apologize.
and it's been kind of hard to disorder do everything that I wanna do
Well, also trying to vlog
Now we're back here my office
Let's have a quick check
Hi!!
So a lot of saying going on
We've been filming 800 Christmas videos and tons of collab videos
But then most I proud of editing all videos, probably I like 15 or 16 videos I edit.
I like get super overwhelming
And said I, "Wow, unbelieving!" that I posting my 'Who am I?' video that's gonna be first of my vlog in December
And I looked at the timeline and I realized I probably had another 7-10 hours editing to do on it
As a quick preview, this is my current timeline
And that brings set about 5 minutes and it feels like y-vlog which is probably bounce of about 40 minutes.
And I'm editing out something, but I've locationed with my family. It was so much fun
But during the vacation, the Mario Odyssey came out, so instead of vlogging or vlogging and editing, while all of the trip
All I did was hanging out Family, it was about that, but I was playing Mario Odyssey.
Goddam look at the game!
look at it, absolutely is fantastic
So if you guys haven't played it and if you get holiday wishlist,  great choice!
This is what I guessed the more  destroyed was is was the easier to film and an entire new vlog.
And the setup is going tons edit to finish this one
There was more posting if you guys to realize that's gonna probably take me at least 4 hours
So I don't figure out managing bunch of many people you guys suppose to be today I just woke up I just gonna talk to you guys for happening
And here we are. I should show you everyone. It's very very nice. My friend Susie got me this. She knows me.
I need some ChapStick.
Is there any here?
SD cards
It better me here
Hair crips. Steve Jobs mini figure. Benny. Me. More hair crips. Philip small.
I need CahpStick!
Oh yeah that's great. That's a lot.
So, in a few videos, you guys are super sneakey
Because you pick out the small details
Think that I'm like, "Oh, they will ever notice it.
A few videos, the pumpkin pie video in particular, and spilling unboxing with Ro
I posted those after I got the iPhone X, we shut and before I had the iPhone X
So, you little detectives you all of the comments I knew this gonna happen to
Well like, "Man, yeah. Maybe they noticed." There's no way I gonna see.
You guys see everything.
It's actually insane.
There's no editing video then before as I'm filming this, I totally as this listen.
I can't have filmed this video because I know every single comment when I post this video
(Your comment) is going to be "Why not using iPhone X?" or...
They plan so far had advance for videos. Also like, "Man, iPhone 11 might be about time post this video."
I've been loving the phone so much. If you haven't been updating videos in... I don't know, like few weeks, just kind like crazy.
I know, I know I was planning on doing a week iPhone, two week iPhone, three week iPhone. Most like a joke, maybe I still should do that, I'm not sure.
Either way, it's been really great. I had very very minimal problems. And the problems that I have had sound like my own fault because that drive me crazy.
It's the middle of the night. I reach over to get my phone. And a half of my face isn't scanned by the pillow and tried to unlock it.
It does not unlock. And then I'm trying to type my passcode.
So I not instant definitely do miss having the home button and being able to use  touch ID.
Before the most part, I think it's great. I did similarly iPhone videos that we get dropped test detected the 21 cases. That was so much fun.
But I was so afraid because the drops redoing again, pretty intense that I have to do over and over again.
So there're I have to say about the iPhone dropped test which was very excited about because they said me the space gray one and I have this over
This is exciting. I thought to get have both phones for like, well, the real course of a day of my iPhone those.
They're all small, if you should kind like have a space gray, it reminds me a jet black phone that we have previously.
I'm so happy with my decision to take this over.
I love that has stenless too the around the edge, it reminds me the first original iPhone, so there's... that a little bit throw back.
Man, it's a just really great device.
Now look at the recording itself.
Let's get
There're a bunch of renders of the iPhone SE each you and this looks really really good, like you guys check this out.
So it's a full screen of the iPhone SE.
I mean gut is the people who get iPhone SE, I feel like it's getting because it has the cost of effective.
But to put in a full screen and to put in all of the future iPhones does make that work?
That's gonna at least cost significantly, so I feel like a kind of the SD cards the purpose having the SE phone, I'm not sure, I don't know.
This is not an apple video. This is just me, my having a chat with my friends, you guys being my friends.
And I do apologize. I'm actually, really really tired today.
Anyway, I work for to you all of the videos that I have coming up this month, so I hope you guys will enjoy them.
And I hope you'll have a holly jolly Christmas!
I've been singing that song probably for two months because I was trying to film the Christmas videos I feel like back in October.
So at this point, for me, I think my Christmas has already, already ended.
Well, see you guys my next video. I will be definitely posting a bunch tomorrow, so make sure you come back.
Be sure to subscribe, if you are new or subscribe already, and of course I have to tell you the hit bell because I don't think the subscriptions really work.
I'm not sure. Notifications are the way to go. If anybody know about the YouTube, let me know. I would love to read the comments below.
How does YouTube work? I've already been here for about 11 to 12 years. And I'm still, I'm not sure.
I'll see you guys later. Bye!
Happy Vlogmas! Sort of Vidmas. I think that's better because not every video I'm posting is gonna be "a vlog."
Bye!